good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this week's episode of the Friday review
of apps this week we are hopefully
coming to you in higher resolution than
usual so you'll hopefully be in a better
position to be able to see some of the
apps which we're demonstrating i'm
joined today by Fred Chung my name is
writer and today we're going to be
checking out well we've got five apps on
the list we'll see how many we get
through we're going to have a look at
settle up 80a oh I keyboard mini wilt
widget are the mute and heart sounds and
murmurs so that's what we will be
checking out right that's good yeah
let's kick let's kick off I would also
hopefully that will hopefully be able to
be joined by some of the developers we
have on hang out which we will art which
will put on screen as well I noticed we
have one person joined us already David
is here right I David I think you okay
yeah I muted um perfect and one which
which happy the developable settle up
perfect alright well let's take a look
at let's take a look at settle up and
before going into apps I like to point
out the title that we are introducing
today on string tight oh okay cell i
taxed out absolutely so actually what
we've got you did you want to tell us a
little bit about settle up while we fire
it up on the air on their devices love
it's an app for
expenses so when you are a group of
people on a trip or somewhere you can
put the payments and put up for the
vulgar so like some advice for gas
somebody paid for accommodation and
stuff like that and at the end the Apgar
quakes rose you so it saves you from
doing this calculation by yourself I
think time it sounds like a nice place
yes synchronization so you can input the
payments into multiple formats first
platform and ready both your grades
that's pretty cool all right let's let's
check it out so I've got it here on me I
mean women can perfect okay so maybe you
want to lose the overlay as well so we
can see the full thing all right perfect
so it's it's a fairly simplistic UI
which is nice um easy to see what's
going on got an action bar there no menu
no menu key so that's nice let's see yep
settings in the overflow menu that's
exactly what we would hope to see and
not a strictly standard setting screen
but it's in line with the rest of the
app we've got the back or the the opti
there which is nice language settings
it's pretty impressive that saddle up is
supporting 18 languages that isn't it
effort that is some efforts right there
or sink really work very nice so one of
the questions I had you know you've got
the ability to pick language here now
that's something which the platform
supports sort of natively is there a
particular reason why you want to give
people the ability to choose the
language rather than just using whatever
the default is for the you know for that
fun yes like for example me like I'm
using my phone in English but I'm free
to go public and I want some of the
absent Czech language catch it right a
lot of checkups to have this option
I can get a good look it gives your
choice to the user stuff but by default
of course it's what you do devices okay
okay let me guess I make that was a
sense okay okay so we got freedom of
reading series which is she's high
energies handy notification a shimmy
shammy yeah it's really really best
about giving people your villages you
turn it on and off some of the features
know tonight's and instead of the
Seminoles much data data opt out doubt
it was always a great discreet app as
well so looking good so far couple of mm
in turn since using busy washboard and
padding it in it so what we most are the
size of the Vice I think I think they
could either be gathered a bigger okay I
think so yeah yeah that's actually is
actually interesting that you chose EU
SEI così pc demonstrators director one
of the rows of reasons why the same
scale s basically expand expand is that
if you've only got a got two icons here
you know there's a bunch of space which
is empty a bunch of white space as you
can see on here and so it feels like
almost new jus new group or join shared
group should be in action on the action
bar rather than you know these these
icons and then you could start right in
it now is this something it just comes
off the very first time yeah it's just
whatever first time this was for the
first time users if you have their items
yeah oh uh HTC myself US dollars should
shed online forget Kurt so one thing
that's one of those for a point hours
out that's why I be great that's what
you like i was using App Engine is a
back-end nicely cool so just so just see
it's doing it's good
Cafferty goes burgers okay okay so if I
just because I just go back injury can
you group for a second i know i just
wanted to point out that on this that
are on this honey no kind of have a
mismatch of YZ lifestyles you can't
leave kinda got the 3m create button at
the bottom you've got the the great
background group not shared online
you've got the new style text added at
the top of this sort of image button
which looks kind of out of place of
three different button styles for the ad
and Groupon share and create so one
thing you may want to consider is to
sort of pick a style and make sure that
everything is consistent within your app
so it all looks kind of the same way
rather than try to have to figure out is
this a button this is not a button that
sort of thing it looks like since you've
taken in efforts to theme the action bar
already I think you know the app can
benefit from you're going for one step
further by theming the I control
elements as wear it to a point it out
cool all right Bala geez alright let's
say let's jump back so we've got the
grip created now so it says what group
we've got in create new payment so again
the same sort of comments here you know
different styles of the same sort of UI
elements something you may want to
consider let's say it's 50 box brings up
a calculator it's nice
too alright so I'll be projecting the
phone right now uh maybe Shaq can
predict the sausages some old okay we
have the most amazing echo it's
absolutely horrible and we think it's
related to the Hangout okay if you're
switching to know I think the only thing
we do is cut hang out at this point but
can um mean one second well Fred masses
right I've already muted this guy I
actually needed here I'll meet on air
right now right now yeah yes they
already all right just one second are we
are mute look oh yes one second miss
right then just just as it is that
should have salted okay so i don't know
whether we're still badly echo hopefully
Billy will be able to tell us in a
couple of seconds our off-screen viewer
to see whether we are still kept going
really badly yeah apologies for the
technical difficulties it is but this is
the first time ever that's right every
time we try and do something new there
it introduces a bunch of new potential
problems right but don't worry sir we're
doing it was still that going as in
you're shaking your head I don't know
whether that means you're coming or not
echoing
apologies ever as we try and work our
way through yeah Billy says thumbs up so
we do I think we're good let's go back
to settle up yeah alright perfect
alright so thanks to settle up apologies
ever on to the for the forensic oh so
we're just going through settle up now
try to check out some of the some of the
features and so as we as we we can match
my via to the phone with the phone can
in if we can switch back to the phone
can possibly know how about a tablet
anything hey can we look at the phone
alright excellent yeah so as we're
looking at this now we can see same same
sort of comments as we had before I'm
not sure how well you had heard those
but it's trying to keep the same sort of
UI elements consistency throughout so
add payment and let's see so I guess 11
comment here it's not entirely clear you
know what the workflow is so we've added
a new payment I presume now if we add
who should pay because there are no
deaths interesting so it's not entirely
clear to me I guess what the with a work
fall is so I guess when you add a new
payment you need to add hi sad the
people as well you have a group and out
of people I assume gotcha so what you
can do is is basically each time you
have a new payment you say who paid for
it and who owed what and those sorts of
things is Rs ok cool there's a great
feature that on this screen that we're
looking at here it's got a camera icon
where I assume you can snatch snap snap
a picture off the receipt for record
purposes that's pretty cool excellent ok
let's have a look so so again even still
at this point I say that the the tablet
i should say the dashboard partner here
is probably not your best bet you
probably want to have these these are
all probably decent action items we have
you just need to sort of figure out what
the what the main screen would mean and
then choose between them see a new new
payment and who should pay settle debts
all seem like there should be you know
the actions for other than being on the
on the home screen but the question
there would have to be you know what
what is the home screen what would you
go into or what are your thoughts there
i think that that's i think for this
particular app since you can either view
debt or add that I think you know it's
probably okay to have the high level of
the most likely used items surfaced up
on the same screen but you probably want
to put some thoughts into how to
has arranged the different icons yeah
okay so let's switch to the to the
tablet you guys number i got this out
later on yeah so this is you know as you
can expect a widened view of what we
just looked at on the Galaxy Nexus
device so there are two versions right
what we look at is the free at sponsored
version and you can see the ads up here
down here actually rather it's actually
in terms of the ad type is the same size
as the one but that was on that little
smaller screen device and so you can
think of you know using a bigger ad type
if available in the particular ad
network to sort of fill up the
application a little bit more it sounds
it sounds almost counterintuitive to
make a bigger ad but in this case it
would actually look better all right so
I think it's definitely worth doing yeah
because of the bigger screen and also
the size of icons we just sort of
similar to and earlier comment on the
size of icons here but on a bigger
screen it becomes more parents that the
icons are too small probably on this
screen size absolutely yeah so let's
have a look at payments log so i have
created a few payments before the
hangout as i was playing around with the
application and you have a list video
showing all the available payment
records and when I tap on it I was on an
assumption that I would actually go into
the detail of the payment but instead a
pop-up came up and which gate which
gives me an edit or delete options so I
think it would make sense to probably do
the Edit payments as soon as you tap on
one of the list views and you get to
this screen and then somewhere on this
screen you exposed to delete payment
option the other users to delete if they
want it to be so what are your thoughts
on that David
I just want to talk more about the
dashboard pattern yeah everything should
be actions when I plot of actions that
are already so I was thinking that it
will be too confusing everything in the
action bar and like these four functions
are like what I'm pitching to the user
which is ok I mean that's a fair home
it's what we found is one of the reasons
why the dashboard pattern is is becoming
less counterintuitive is because it kind
of it works in in your instance but but
kind of that that's almost the edge case
as soon as you have more than sort of
four things it's not clear how you
expand that and if you look at it on the
tablet in particular it's a great
example because you've got sort of your
four icons sort of swimming in the
middle of this large space and so that
you know that's one of the challenges
that you have when when you're using
dashboard you know certainly does give
you the the right sort of pathway into
showing what the key elements are but if
you have a look at something like google
maps which does something similar like
it's they've got like a bunch of sort of
sub apps within there's like latitude
and places and all those things all
available from that spinner that that
tends to be more of a preferred way
because it scales better and it makes it
easier for you to figure out how you're
going to make that layout work on
tablets in principle it's fine but like
I say if you look at the tablet version
you can see where the drawbacks are you
just got this for little icons and in
the middle of the screen yeah it's too
much these fragments and stuff for
example good night
yeah the last thing I want to point out
is that under the overflow menu you have
remove ads and more it's an upsell
option basically directing the user via
an intent to goo what do so you go
through this dialog box and then if the
user hits by you bring the user to the
google play store with the peg as the
paid version of your application so this
is for totally perfect implementation
but also you know one thing that you can
consider using is in app purchase
available for applications and the
second thing they like to point out is
that it's more for the intent flag so
really as if you remember from settle
app now that we are at the Google Play
client you can think of it as an
activity stack so if the user at this
point tabs on home it goes back to the
home screen as expected but if the user
goes back to settle up now this previous
scene Google Play client popped up
because it's on top of the activities
deck so when you're in but instead when
I let me go back when I tap on the setup
icon expect it to go into your
application instead of seeing stuff
another application which currently
happens to be on top of the saddle up
tet deck so when you fire the intent for
bringing up the Google Play landing page
for your paid application there's a flag
that you can set yeah and that flag is
called flag activity on magnitude we're
all from my this is Michael Germany with
fear when task reset so if you look look
into a look at the google android
developers stream that's one of the
clothes from diane i believe that talks
about this kind of interactions that's
something that you can avoid a dress
today
annual hollywood but that's all i think
all i know this is a very practical
application yeah definitely useful yeah
yeah nice one so yeah thanks for joining
us and a nice work i think there's a few
things you can do there particularly the
the tips which which Fred pass along and
just like I say just you your user
experience your UI design is good like
it's it's definitely it's definitely a
nice looking at it feels clean it's not
clothed but I think you know the key
thing you need to maybe check out in
order to sort of think about taking out
to the next level is making sure you
have a nice clean consistent you I've
preferably something which on my ice
cream sandwich device looks native for
ice cream sandwich so using the the
modern flat buttons and text edits and
all those sorts of things and then also
just thinking about how you want the app
to work on on tablets and so if even if
you're not doing a full sort of tablet
redesign which which I think would be a
valuable thing just thinking about how
everything should expand to fill the
space in a kind of a logical way I think
would be a good first step great that's
nice you're running us today cool
alright let's let's move on its own
let's have a look at the ATA oh I
keyboard now I think you've managed to
get it installed on now yes I have nice
and high dance I have it's the developer
with us no I don't think so all right
maybe next time so let's let me fire up
say gmail right gmail
alright this is my test screen so here's
the IME it's interesting um so I have no
idea but I think you know there must be
a purpose for a certain demographic so
and i probably need probably need to
spend what time practice and yeah i
think if he hears it's supposed to be
fast it's supposed to be a right i think
a sort of scenario right so if you so my
cursor is up here and if you do some
swiping and tapping you see text but
let's let's have a look just listen we
can work it out so let's um look
logically i'm gonna try and type um
let's go with you know that's
interesting android oh okay yeah hey at
the end it's kind of and my
understanding is that for some
characters you have to swipe on one of
the keys so it's it's not obvious if I
that's the backspace this wiring so I
think that way is giving me gee it's
interesting interesting and anta doesn't
really give me a every time but if you
switch to you'll be able to switch how I
roll okay so I can i yeah what I can't
do that but I think that's a view where
there's a help screen but I think one
sort of feedback from a technical angle
is that when you tap on any of these
keys you don't get the visual feedback
is has something for in any battle hit
ya so I think one of the challenges
years that is pretty baffling if you
haven't been given the instructions is
what I want to spend some time
practicing using your side and I think
it might be useful to have something
like that bills built into the app sort
of an easy way to get a tutorial up from
this screen given it's not obvious
exactly how how it's used so that's part
of that's our fault for not spending a
little bit more time figuring out
but just looking at the sort of looking
of the UI by itself one of the things I
want to mention is that it's it's quite
it's quite blocky so its bigger takes up
a lot of the screen closer look at it
here do you have it under bouncing
exercise I do I haven't actually figured
out how to add a brand I'm I don't chew
your comments yes maybe perfect oh yes
oh this is nice so one of the things
which I like about a lot of the custom
keyboards is that they do look really
polish they look really nice and giving
the keyboardist home which is going to
come up a lot it's worth spending that
time to really make it to round the
edges and really polish it up and make
it look you know really slick and that's
something which I think this particular
keyboard could do a good job off so
things like the the the input like the
the feedback to show you that you've
actually touched something or actually
on the phone version has got there some
instructions ice all right let's so
let's switch to the phone in the photo
yeah and I maybe should hopefully be
able to yell it a little bit more
guidance thank you all right all right
let's get many to go bigger hair that's
the way almost yes perfect okay so it
does not a cheat sheet but I have to
admit that the cheat sheet is not
helping me a lot here so it shows me how
to do it Vodacom's oh so I can swipe
through so that's quite handy so as I'm
swiping through the tutorial I point out
that would be useful for this to be more
of a viewpager implementation so that i
can see that swiping is actually doing
something can you do a view of patron
and I am I haven't done I've done so I
don't know the answer to
if you can't do a new pager it would be
useful to at least you know have it sort
of pan smoothly in the same way right so
until the whoops half the blue key once
for a green tea 40 yellow for a orange
40 and read for space slide up starting
from red key for my interesting to
delete a single character slide up
starting from the blue key to delete
five characters and once slide down
starting from the blue key okay that's
some practicing so this this is a this
is this is kind of a complicated
scenario so what I was what I would
definitely provide feedback but I'd be
interested to find out how many users
you haven't if this is designed around
us a specific use case you know if this
is implementing sort of unknown keyboard
pattern right that's why I'm wondering
too yeah or is this just totally
invented from scratch because if it's
from scratch I think you're going to
find it quite difficult to ER to train
people to use this keyboard because it's
it's complicated it's very complicated
in terms of like I say in terms of the
look and feel so leaving aside the
functionality and how easy it is to use
I think the key stuff here is that you
want to be providing more feedback and
so as I'm pressing these things while
things are happening it's not clear
which key that I am touching so I
definitely want to be able to see you as
I do a finger down I want to see the
blue the green key which everyone i've
selected change color or change today in
some way so that i know that i've done
that and then if there's a way to be
able to provide some on-screen
assistance so that i know what to do
next that would also be be very valuable
as i start to drag to give some idea of
you know what what is this going to do
yes because we know that maybe you can
introduce a beginner mode versus and a
dance I'm sure after a week or so if we
actively using we can be experts exact
using it
beginners like us right now it would be
very helpful to have some sort of visual
cue and instructions which you have but
it can probably use some improvements
notice for us the other thing I think I
point out so on the on the phone here
it's it fits perfectly along the bottom
which is as you'd expect and you'll note
that on the tablet it was sort of stuck
just on the left-hand bottom corner so
that's something that you want to look
at make sure that the that whatever the
optimization is that it works on a
variety of devices try to put this into
landscape mode so as soon as I put it
into landscape I get the same effect
with the key is just on the bottom left
sort of not spreading out now that may
be intentional but I think it's
something that you want to consider like
you know I would think of its supposed
to be fast sort of easy to reach with
your thumb type typing then a better
approach you know a landscape mode be
just split it up on either side so
you've got thumbs on either side so
that's something to consider as well
just how does how does this keyboard
work on different so I screens different
layouts different devices those sorts of
things
but definitely interesting definitely
interesting i think so too yeah like to
get some feedback from the developers
your online or give us comments we would
love to hear from you we can maybe take
another look at the app once we also
have a or maybe just have a chat on a
hangout and find out yeah a little bit
more about it seems interesting want to
be educated on this absolutely yeah all
right so move on to a minimal Twitter
we're gonna have to hammer through these
because we don't want to eat into the
the games review you get to take
advantage of our an attitude to have a
much more polished production at two
o'clock exactly all right so minimal
twitch it let's have a look here I've
got it on the phone I will see I'll
press the thing see what it does so it's
a widget which is nice so once you were
when you click it on the from the
launcher icon to give some instructions
as to how to get started which is nice
tells you so i think i read through the
instructions and i think it pointed they
pointed out okay if you're running pre
honeycomb i believe uh you did okay pre
gingerbread it directs you to use one
particular version but if you're running
honeycomb or above it asks you to use
another version so that's a great use
case where you can explore something
like multiple apks if something that if
this is something that you can't fit
into one APK but our general guideline
is to is to fit the functionality into a
single APK so that on your google play
app listing you have a single listing
then imma get a lot less confusing so
has been as you at 0 is trying to yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna try and add it but
if you've already got it on yoga okay
now let's switch you to the tablet
tablet alright so what we're looking at
okay let me go back to home screen and I
tap on to it Bridget so I'm looking at
the same instruction activity that rato
just showed us with a bunch of you
shins and as I mentioned earlier make
sense for you to so at least explore
combining the features into a single APK
okay so there are some instructions and
I go back and I've previously added this
widget here so let's but let's go
through the education again so I need to
login to twitter interesting I can find
find the widget and let me place it on
the home screen here find an available
spot and it gives you a bunch of tweets
and I previously set up my accounts this
is my so does the resourceful widget
which is handy right it's going to
scroll view in here and there are it's
sort of replicated the action bar you I
here and the fingers do yeah because I
think it makes sense because users are
accustomed to using the action bar and
all the action bar icon as you notice is
the theam it's a nice idea but the
actual touch targets look really really
small all right I think it's been
struggling to hit those so it sort of
suggests maybe making them a little bit
bigger to make them easier for people to
to actually touch right that's good
feedback otherwise it looks nice yeah
and that's touching one of these it
brings you to the settings screen which
looks pretty stamped it allows you to
update refresh rate and whether you want
to enable notifications or not yeah this
is a widget centric Twitter view
absolutely can we go back to the back to
the home screen and have a look so what
else can we do from the M so mainly this
is about just showing showing tweets on
your home screen so what happens if you
click on one there's a
you too nothing okay all right it brings
up and embedded well so it's so it's
easy it opens the app itself and then
puts a puts the link in the web view
that's interesting since this is
pointing to a link it opens up over web
is what opens the link okay there's some
intelligence into it its interest so on
the bottom there I feel menu items close
if I star it well let's go back to the
same so I guess it's this is so this is
where you can do the the general Twitter
thing so reshare star reshare will open
up a dialogue to the to lady to do that
so that's that's quite nice when you
think of the layout oh that's
interesting I mean in this instance you
can see obviously you're taking up a
huge amount of space on the tablet so
i'm going to i'm going to go ahead and
guess it's not really being
tablet-optimized i'm interested if this
is the actual so it's actually embedding
the advert so it's reading what's in the
link and abetting that within it it's
kind of an interesting approach yeah
let's tap on another tweet without vlog
without langless out cnn's go ahead all
of my tweets earth links of course
this one okay it just shows you if if a
twit message doesn't have a length it
doesn't even better right what this does
is actually show it is interesting is
that the actual sort of instruction
stuff is just behind it so obviously
that's their main activity and then
popping up the the tweet details
activity on top and in this instance
that's not great you kind of have a
weird experience we've kind of got this
half well it makes it very hard to read
yeah exactly so what you probably want
to be doing there is is not having to
activity so make the tweet tweet details
activity be full like full screen so
that the the whole thing is there and
then sort of array your things
accordingly so you shouldn't you
shouldn't really have these sorts of
actions jumping around differently based
on the size of the tweet you really want
to have that consistent so the actions
should always be along the bottom or
always a lot at the top either way they
should sort of consistently be in the
same place that's good to back and these
the user can focus on yourself razon
what's beneath no no no you know seeing
as you're using you're using the action
bar pattern on the Twitter tweet on the
rigid itself I'd consider doing the same
sort of thing within the the details
view here so have this set up as a
normal activity with the the reply
retweet star and close actions up the
top and in fact you don't really need
the X that I think just means close
right it just exits out of of this
actually yeah taxing is closed exactly
so I would probably just eliminate that
you just really need the back button to
take you back to the wall to close that
activity really would be kind of nita
right yeah so i would i think that the
widget itself looks great i do know that
this is an alpha version so obviously
there's still some development to be
done here in right on by the dev the
toilet the widget itself looks great i
would like i said earlier make those
touch targets bigger so that people can
actually hit them and then sort of i'd
say work on the
the tweet view between details view a
little more and try and build that up to
the same stand and I think you'll have
something quite interesting all right
it's great shall we move on oh we should
I think it one more time I will skip
heart sounds and learners for next week
I think and we'll check out our d mute
which I think it's also a widget is that
right no it's it's an interesting app
that only works on two little many
devices haha because so apparently they
have some innovative ways to
automatically built a device so
considering if you are driving or if
you're in a meeting if you put your
telephony device face down it
automatically moves you alright so
that's pretty interesting let's never
look at it alright so we open it up oh
look it's my phone they're using sounds
quite handy that works I'm having it
needs your phone when you flip down
place your phone ok so what I've noticed
is that there are really three things
it's trying to showcase but it tends to
skip over the middle it really does yeah
it's almost impossible to get the
company if I want to work on the physics
a little bit yeah so I think the easy
answer here is use the viewpager instead
because what you're using him doesn't
really work is really careful i can get
it yeah it's a photo jump yeah but just
a normal swipe just skip spine straight
past carload now you could leave it as
it is but make Jedi mode the one in the
middle and then you kind of have to be a
Jedi to figure out Jedi mode I kind of
like that this is a synchronicity there
that works for me but car mode I think
you don't want that to be quite so
invisible ok so i'll see you next so
again the this is a nice looking app in
general but there's really no reason why
this this wizard shouldn't be full
screen sort of being able to see half an
activity behind it just cuddles right so
I'd stop that and also the the next the
next button you've got down here like it
hey it looks really out of place and
beads kind of unnecessary if you're
doing the swipe the swiping stuff you
don't really need X yeah so is there a
page educator all right there isn't
there's no page indicator so maybe
that's a good more thing yeah to show
people I think nowadays are trained to
interact to know what to do or how to
interpret things aya exactly so replace
the next with the indicator so people
know that supposed to swipe we're close
we get hermosa license to read through
them yeah oh you don't read i got that I
ok good ok service does so my initial
reaction is that ok I see the service
status led the graphics looks nice but
it I don't have the contacts yes right
pretty meaningless at the moment right
so let's have a look we hit I it gives
us information about the developer ?
shows us what we've seen before ok and
settings ok so settings is where we
actually turn it on and off that's
interesting so at the moment is going to
do nothing unless we turn the air unless
we turn the service on and then you can
set up a bunch of exception so this this
all looks nice yeah I'm going to
to put that in using a different
keyboard farmer Jedi mode so it's all
these settings are all perfectly
appropriate using this standard settings
ya brain which is nice as well what I
would comment on though is if you're
looking at this main screen you've kind
of got the pseudo action bar thing
happening no menu button which is nice
but I turn this into an actual actual
action bar where possible so on on this
device it certainly would work and all
three of these items here should really
be in the overflow menu there they're
not sorry key things this this is about
the app also i just want to point out
the about screen i can't think of a
justifiable reason why the about screen
would go full screen please don't do
that it's it's just frustrating it
doesn't really achieve anything and so
why would i would actually do is have
all three of these in the overflow menu
and have one action which is enabled
disabled so that's straight away you
know how to you know turn it on turn it
off right yeah specially you know when I
walk into the car and I want to pretty
convenient way to turn it on right but
serato you have to launch the app go
ahead and still into the setting and you
know I've checked the checkbox see if i
get bessica that's the gesture that I
can't quite you know figure it out put
it face down however when it faces down
it works i tested in 15 times this
morning and Billy Roy Rachel's asking me
why are you calling yourself not do it
all the time okay all right yeah the
other thing I'd point out is that the
sort of the screen here it does nothing
and so if you've got all of the space
again server status Rosalie it wasn't
clearly with that man so obviously means
whether or not the RDA mute service has
enabled which is ax be turned on so you
know what you maybe you want to pull
that right out of the settings and put
it right here on the main screen like
service status you know just say is it
on or is it often have a big red button
you can press to turn it on if it isn't
I think that's going to be much more
sort of useful you want to make it
really easy for people to get started
like I want to start this up press the
big enable button and then flip it on
its face and hear it tell me something
which is the other thing you may want to
have on this home screen is tell me is
is the ringer disabled what is the
ringer volume so I've got the ringer on
now alright doesn't have a notification
I think you can turn them on ok no no
donations but I you know if I open the
app I want that to tell me everything
the notification definitely no arm so
that's that's definitely something you
want to be a little bit more informative
you and maybe bring some of that stuff
from settings put it on the home screen
make it easier for users to understand
like what is it what do I have to do to
make it do something new doesn t look
out that they told us I have all right
now cool all right so it's been a bit of
a rough session today we apologize again
for the bad echo with the beginning
hopefully that's all sorted out we're
going to take off clear the room for
down in and dance hat for the Friday
review of games and it's got a new hat
today he's always got a new hat yes I'm
going to see if we can make him bring a
new heart every week it's going to be a
challenge but I kind of think dad's up
to it no it's not going to be challenged
what that nice doctor so hopefully they
won't have any echo problems and you'll
be able to see the games that they're
reviewing in full 720 high def so thank
you for joining us we'll be doing this
every week Friday's one o'clock if you
want to nominate your own games for
games or apps for review there is a
moderator page which we will be sharing
on the android developers google+ page
which you can get to at
developer.android.com / + your
convenient reference and yeah we'll see
you all next week alright thanks very
much
you